[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about at
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
the journalist and a researcher at
Sheffield University Remmy our decoy
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
coming on we really look forward to
talking to you and before we get into
the meat in the substance of what we
talk about tell us a little bit about
how you here what's been your background
just a little bit about that for our
viewers so they know who you are well I
was born in Nigeria to a Nigerian father
and a Polish mother I grew up in Nigeria
went to a primary secondary school in
Nigeria and then after that in the late
90s I moved to Poland which was where my
mum was from went to university in
Poland first studied law but couldn't
find myself as a lawyer and then later
on moved into journalism became a
political journalist in Poland I really
enjoyed that but I decided to move to
the UK about three years ago and do a
PhD here in politics in political
science so that's that's about it and we
talked a little bit about what you're
researching you talked about group
identity which is something we'll touch
on I'm sure and but tell us a little bit
about your political kind of evolution
how you came to have the views that
we'll be talking about a little bit as
well which views exactly well why don't
we just get into the views that nobody's
it for anyone who hasn't discovered Remy
until this point you wrote an article
for you write for the Guardian as well
but you wrote an article for Colette
which I think got a lot of people's
attention including ours and for anyone
who hasn't read it we'll put it in in
the in the YouTube below but tell us a
little bit about what was the kind of
the gist the crux of your article for
anyone who hasn't seen it well the crux
of the article was essentially based on
a conversation essentially I had
with a friend of mine a black friend of
mine and it was about how we discuss
race when I say we I mean black people
in public and in private and how there's
a big difference usually and there are
calculations which are made regarding
what we should say in public and what we
shouldn't say in public these
calculations are essentially based on
how many black people view our interests
so essentially I'd say maybe on
self-preservation instincts like I wrote
in the article about how ok I was
talking to this friend of mine and he
was complaining about black friend of
his at the workplace who sort of you
know plays the race card anytime there's
a there's a difficult situation with a
white person yeah
the friend is like friend of my friend
it's like oh you know bring out the race
card and most likely ninety-nine percent
of the time a white person will back
down so my friend told me oh he finds
this disgusting doesn't like it this is
completely wrong etc and in this
conversation we were having
I said yeah exactly so that's why we
have to start criticizing this you know
black identity Rian's and people sort of
you know trying to essentially leverage
some of the horrors which ancestors went
through for some form of advantage today
ok then my friend said well actually I
don't agree with you on that you know
and I'm like you know why but you just
said now that you don't like people
leveraging leveraging race like this and
he says yeah but actually if you look at
the big picture you'll find out that
look he says look let's think about it
how many of those black people are there
here in the UK
ok about 5% of the population do we have
a lot of economic and political power no
we don't ok that's the reality now what
is actually preventing the white
population about 87 percent who control
almost all the political and economic
power from actually dominating us
overtly my friend asked me the only
thing that's stopping them from doing
that is the fear of being called racists
yeah it's political correctness is the
restraints which has been placed on them
by society regarding how they should
talk to minorities yeah and he says
that's the only saving grace we actually
have and he says take that away and what
do we have take that away and we could
have a situation like we had in the 70s
and the 80s okay where people on the
road you know using the n-word freely
and don't feel afraid to do that because
there's you know no social ostracism no
social consequences from doing that so
they're gonna people are gonna be doing
it and he's like what was interesting
here my friend with a very intelligent
guy very successful banking city in
London I said it's not because you know
white people are evil or something like
that
but he said that's simply human nature
if you put people in a position of
dominance over another group of people
and they're not checks okay they are
going to abuse that position so his
argument is essentially then you need
white guilt to protect minorities yes
that without white guilt we'd be in a
much more difficult situation here and
essentially you know white people sort
of wouldn't have any restraints towards
you know talking to us anyhow or using
exploiting that advantage which they do
have of us in numbers in political power
in economic power etc so he's like you
know that's the only restraint so he
sees that as a sort of necessary evil
he's like I don't like it aesthetically
morally I don't really like it but I
think we need it you know in order to
protect ourselves cause it's all we've
got
if we let go of that if we black people
start criticising identity politics
black identity Rian's
then and mainstream white society says
well you know since it seems that if a
black people don't agree with his
identity reans then you know maybe why
bother with this whole you know
political correctness thing and he's
like looking at that in the long term
it's actually going to be bad for us and
what do you make of that argument Sir
Francis look that argument I'd be lying
if I told you that argument I was like
oh that's rubbish it's an argument which
made me think I actually you know
started imagine imagining certain
scenarios I started actually thinking
okay fine what if tomorrow now you know
political correctness was simply you
know dubbed unnecessary by mainstream
white society because there's obviously
already a segment of society which says
it's rubbish but I'm talking of
mainstream majority sixty seventy
percent of the people what if they
actually say
Posca lightness is rubbish actually we
should be able to say anything we like
more or less - black people etc would
that be a more pleasant environment for
me to live in being a minority here in
numbers I can't imagine it being yeah
it's that way to be the case if it were
to go in that direction that people
would want to exploit that advantage so
like I said I couldn't I definitely
didn't you know think what my friend was
saying was rubbish but I thought about
it and the thing is you know maybe it's
I don't know maybe it's naive or
something but based on my experiences
with especially people here in the UK
because I've had different experiences
also in Poland at different kettle of
fish but based on my experience with
people here in the UK I do believe
fundamentally that a majority of the
white population here does not have
racist instincts and would not exploit
to their advantage
yeah if you know the whole race thing
and the numbers advantage they have and
the particular advantage they have if
say political correctness theoretically
was to disappear that's what I believe
that is a fundamental decency in most
people who live here
I believe that two-three hundred percent
based on experiences which I've had
based on experiences and my twin
Nigerian work life is 100 percent
Nigerian she's actually lived in the UK
a bit longer than me counting and
intervals and all that and based on her
experience also you know based on things
we talk about based on experiences of
some other people when we actually sit
down and talk because you know sometimes
black people may complain about racism
here but you know when we sit down when
I say we when we black people sit down
in the room you know and I'm like what
guys come on you know these people
really actually pretty tolerant like
yeah yeah of course we know you know but
you know we can't we shouldn't sort of
say that out we sort of have to keep up
that moral pressure yeah just to make
sure they don't want be taken into their
heads to start exploiting those
advantages of us and fitness DVDs should
features 20 30 years ago so it's not
like people don't know this it's not
like a lot of people who might even you
know retweet the
black identity Rian's you know for lack
of a better term and post on twitter
saying maybe not the most radical ones
but let's just see something sort of
insinuating that there's a lot of racism
in the UK it's not like every black
person who retweets that actually really
believes it's that bad okay but it's
just part of you know keeping up this
pressure and part of you know trying to
sort of MSU protect ourselves from this
white power which a lot of people
actually fear you know and as I argued
in the in the piece that's historical
reasons of course for that fear but
doesn't the rise of something of someone
like Trump in the u.s. yeah I mean that
their fears actually well-founded
because although obviously I'm not black
I'm half Latin American and when Trump
came out and did the speech and talked
about Mexicans and immigrants some of
them are racists know some of that
summer sort of saw him the more rapists
immediately I had a sinking sensation
inside and if I went to the US in
certain areas I wouldn't feel
comfortable speaking Spanish which is my
second language hmm of course and you
know there's no pretending I know we'd
be silly to pretend here that is you
know no such thing as racism oh it's a
very you know marginal thing which you
know only 5% of the white population
you know subscribe to and all that no
that's not the way it is is something
which is very real and exists among more
than five or ten percent of the white
population in standard let's say Western
society so of course that exists and
Trump paradoxically has only
strengthened you know identity politics
among minority minority sort of
intellectuals because they're like see
we told you guys you guys were saying
these white people you know that I'm a
they are not that racist they're not
that bad etcetera etcetera now do you
see look who they voted for they voted
for a guy who said all the things he
said so even the black people before I
focus on black that's the community I
know obviously the other minority groups
even the black people before who were
sort of neutral or didn't buy into those
narratives that oh essentially every
second white person is racist
you know sort of now feel sometimes a
little bit silly thinking actually I was
naive yeah it seems this white folk are
actually pretty racist I mean they did
vote for this Trump guy who said all
those things so you know maybe I was the
one who was naive and not these identity
politics guys yeah maybe they were the
ones who were right yeah and there's
some others who say yeah well of course
you know Trump doesn't represent all
white people etc etc but since there is
such a political force right now we
definitely need to stand on the side of
our people okay and defend our people
who are being attacked by this kind of
politics so even if we don't agree
ninety or much less one hundred percent
with the black identity Rian's we
definitely need to hold the line with
them because you know these are the guys
fighting for us definitely Trump is not
fighting for us and the people who
support Trump are definitely not
fighting for us okay so it's sort of a
it's it's bad for people like me but
it's a strong word it's difficult for
people like me because now there's a
line drawn yeah so it's a you know are
you with them or are you with us okay I
do with the Trump folk who are saying
the things they're saying are you with
us who are trying to you know sort of
resist the Trump folk you know so it's
it's tricky right now it's the
polarizing effect of Trump it pushes
everyone into the corner doesn't it but
I mean in terms of it's interesting
because Donald one things Donald Trump
always talks about is that black
unemployment is the lowest that it's
been decades wherever I think and you
know Donald Trump got more of the ethnic
minority vote than any of the previous
Republican candidates for four decades
as well not necessarily
he got 29 percent of the Hispanic votes
which is roughly the percentage any
Republican candidate gets is roughly
what McCain got Mike ain't even got more
I think if I remember correctly so he
didn't get a larger percentage of the
Hispanic vote he didn't get a larger
percentage of the black vote what
happened was that much fewer minority
voters especially black voters came out
to vote in 2016 for Hillary Clinton
they simply stayed at home
okay so in when Obama was then even when
Clinton was there okay Bill Clinton I
mean sort of minority voters black
voters were more mobilized to come out
on votes but Hillary Clinton was not
able to mobilize an ethnic minority
voters especially black voters so it's
not necessarily the case that Trump got
a higher percentage of those you know
that minority vote than a regular
Republican candidate would get but
Hillary Clinton got less than definitely
what Obama got in 20 in 2008 and 2012
and you think the rise of identity
politics is a positive thing do you
think it's helped us it's become a
dismal where or do you think it's
ultimately quite divisive what do you
mean by all of a society okay
that is important to a mare to know
we're talking about definitely if you
see all of our society has identity
politics helped us I would say you know
first of all it depends you know how we
define this identity politics now if we
define for instance what Martin Luther
King was doing in the late 60s as
identity politics and there are
definitions of identity politics by
which we could describe that as an
Interpol in the sense of focusing on the
interests of a specific ethnic group
okay and articulating those interests in
in political fashion but these were
interests of a specific ethnic group
okay which he was focused on yeah later
on he actually started talking about a
lot about poverty and all that which
encompasses all ethnic groups but let's
just say most of his work and definitely
what he's associated with is on
defending black interests yeah that's
the way it is if we describe that as
identity politics then I would
definitely say it has helped because it
brought a larger degree of Furness in
u.s. society for a specific group of
people no one would criticize the civil
rights movement
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so if so yeah so again
if we look at but obviously when we talk
about identifies easily we are not
thinking about that yeah we're thinking
about identity on politics I don't want
start naming names and you know people
basically coming out and you know
bringing up terms like you know white
privilege and white fragility and
essentially you know if white person
doesn't agree with us let's say me a
black person's and the definition of
racism that means that black that white
person is racist yeah which is
absolutely rubbish in my own opinion so
that kind of identity politics of
focusing sort of solely because even
when Martin Luther King was articulating
his arguments for why black people
should be treated fair in America these
his arguments were based on a broad
understanding of universal human rights
in America he was essentially saying
look the American Constitution said all
men are created equal so how come it
seems now that that doesn't apply to
black men yeah okay so he was
essentially sort of appealing to a
universal universal human rights
universal sense of decency let's just
call it that what it is right now we
don't have that there's no appeal that
oh well actually we just want you know
black people to be treated how everybody
else is treated and all that it's more
essentially like oh well you know
there's this loads of bad things which
have happened slavery colonialism racism
institutionalized racism in the 60s 70s
80s etc black people have you know
suffered from this white people it seems
don't want to recognize this and you
know sometimes I wonder you know when
they say sort of like white people don't
want to recognize which white people are
you talking about is it on to every
single white person on this planet Earth
acknowledges the
evils of racism slavery etc that we will
finally see oh yeah okay now it's okay
because I mean what how many white
people have to acknowledge these things
for it to be accepted that Oh white
people have acknowledged it since I
don't know if you're following the
argument I'm making what you need ninety
nine percent yeah ninety-five oh it's 92
okay yeah yeah because you know I would
definitely argue that in majority
definitely in Western societies have
acknowledged this okay and they've been
books written about this they've been
films made about this even laws which
are created for instance in in the
contracting governments speak about this
what I mean I apologize for race as many
as it only doubled for real phrase in
the slavery theories army Amanda was
there was a government report which came
out last I think it was 2017 talking
about you know disparities in
socio-economic outcomes and the report
very clearly stated that look there is a
link here between race and huge
disparities in socio-economic outcomes
okay in the UK regarding employment
regarding housing etc and we need to
tackle this okay this is a Tory
government for God's sake and they've
acknowledged that so what else do you
want sort of how many people have to say
oh yes this is a problem we acknowledge
it but it's a clever argument from their
point of view because they can actually
push the argument until the last white
man acknowledges that which they know is
never going to happen yes
okay which they know he's never going to
happen they're always gonna be white
people who are gonna try it all well you
know well you know maybe not exactly or
maybe wasn't that bad at all there are
people who sort of use yeah so it's an
argument which they can essentially push
for eternity so it's a very clever
tactic in order to essentially advance
the agenda whatever that definitely
because you can always point you can
always find races yeah oh you can always
say oh well they say that racism doesn't
exist in the West anymore
but look at what politician a said yes
and look at what Minister exit is that
not really
which shows you they're still a problem
okay so is then magnified and portrayed
as a problem as in something which
effects or these are views shared by a
large group of people whereas it's one
individual for instance who made a
statement yeah I think part of the
problem for me is is that how we don't
discuss it like your article and I loved
I thought it was brilliant and I said to
Constantine this is great we need we
need to get you on the show and I shared
it with one of my friends who's mixed
race yeah we have never spoken about it
yeah and he's never mentioned it or any
shape or form and did you feel a push
back from from that article from to be
honest there are a lot of people who
really know what's going on and see the
BS of the identity reans
okay so the answer to your question is
that the overwhelming majority of like
let's see the people on my social media
feed etc black people etc didn't you
know criticize me for that or say oh
that's wrong we disagree with that okay
some openly said this is exactly what
our thoughts all this while okay
some kept quiet but definitely didn't
like unfollow me or something like that
I mean continue the engagement with me
and what they were definitely a few who
am one term which I'd remember which you
know I'd be pretty you know we all try
to act as if you know we're tough and we
don't care what other people say and all
that's and all that which is generally
the way it should be but it's not the
way you know emotionally we are as
people
yeah so when for instance you know
someone who had been a good friend of
mine at least you know social media and
all that you know told me oh they were
disappointed in me for writing that I'd
be lying if I said you know that didn't
make me sort of like hmm like wow let me
rethink actually what I just said and
what might be the effects for people
because you know it's easy to write
something but there are consequences for
what you write especially if let's say
the article you know is read by more
than a few people and they are real
concern
for people in real life or at least they
may perceive those people may perceive
that they may be cons there may be
consequences so what I'm essentially
saying is that there were only a few
people who sort of you know pushed back
I said you know this is wrong
which of which I said the most sort of
the one that you know really sort of you
know made me stop and you know I think -
I wanna said oh I'm disappointed in you
in the sense I expected more from you
but then I sat down and thought about
and said okay what does this actually
mean what does this person actually mean
what they actually mean is that I know
what they mean
that's the black person I know how I
know the conversations that go on you
know when they are no white people in
the room I know what what they
essentially mean is that look we know
okay what you wrote is the way it is but
at the end of the day we can't trust
these people okay we know what they've
done to us in the past we know what some
of them are saying about us today so how
can you sort of reveal outside some of
the strategies and tactics which we use
in order to defend ourselves against
them okay so it's essentially based on a
fundamental emotional very often
mistrust okay that look at the end of
the day this is why people don't like us
so much okay they might pretend they
might smile they might even because of
certain laws you act as if they do maybe
even give us a couple of jobs etc etc
but fundamentally in the deepest heart
of hearts
these white people don't really like us
too much for some reason that's a strong
belief which is held among many many
again I'm speaking of black people some
super intelligent with huge degrees and
all that and all that even very
successful it's a fundamental belief
which is deep down you know it's
something which is emotional okay you
can try to you can't interact
intellectualize it you can't argue with
it on an intellectual level you know
it's something which is based on emotion
me say for instance you know this might
be probably a flawed analogy hugely
flawed analogy but it's the way for
instance people in Israel Jews might
reacts to you know em talk of you know
surrounding you know the Holocaust or
people sort of you know anti-semitic
remarks etc you know there is definitely
I would argue a feeling there among many
Israeli Jews that look generally the
group is under some kind of threat we
have a lot of enemies okay there are
people who hate us
they're people who want to see us
exterminated in fact from this F and we
have to be worried of them okay we have
to always be conscious of that that
these enemies exist a lot of people
don't like us it's a feeling which exist
I think you guys would would agree even
some time on intellectuals also in
Jewish intellectuals etc who
theoretically we would say should know
that oh you can't generalize like that
but you know these are emotions yeah I
think people feel it in the people so
these things exist so these feelings
among black very often it's emotional
yeah it's based from that something you
know we've read those books about
slavery we've read those books about
colonialism and all those things which
happened you know and of course another
point which is not usually raised today
which I know exists is that a lot of
let's see what's the word I would use
for it now not suspicion in this case
but where were nice we could say oh and
let's even say bringing in some
resentment into it is because of the
fact that you know we haven't been able
to as black people build many oh so much
even I do any successful black nations
powerful black nations okay I guarantee
you that if there were say five or six
African economies you know to three
trillion dollar ma gdp economies with
powerful armies with nuclear weapons
believe me black people wouldn't be half
as sensitive to some of these debates
and some of these let's say insults
which flow around as they are today okay
so that those that aggressive reaction
also often stems from essentially a
sense of fundamental weakness group
weakness okay
they're obviously some hugely successful
individual black people there's the
Obamas as the Oprah Winfrey's the
African billionaires popular African
musicians etc okay there's no doubt
about that professionals lawyers etc but
as a group in Vatican in group terms
there is a sense of fundamental weakness
there okay and that is what also
sometimes make these reactions over
sensitive yeah which you know cuz it's
like you know if there's a classroom and
guy who is one of the you know school
boys who is you know really big he's got
muscles etc if let's see one of the
smaller boys you know taunts him you
know he essentially laughs it off he
doesn't take it serious you know but if
it goes the other way around and it's
the muscular jock let's say who taunts
the smaller skinny boy the smallest
skinny boy feels it much more and he
will react much more emotionally to it
because he's in that position of
disadvantage and he doesn't feel strong
I see quite a lot with Venezuelan people
because of what's happening in Venezuela
and the fact that the country has been
so chronically mismanaged and as a
result that though there is that sense
of you know frustration and also a sense
of inferiority and once and also when
you talk with Venezuelan people they
there's a sense that sometimes a sense
of almost hopelessness of like we we
can't make it work whatever reason I
don't know if that's been your
experience of what you've just discussed
that's just been mine when I talk to
Venezuelan people because of everything
that's happening in Latin America of not
that the vast majority of countries
simply aren't functioning but I find
that surprising I mean in Venezuela
obviously we know and there we know the
case but I'm surprised you see that
might be happening in Latin America
countries they're doing very well I mean
presented generally doing not bad yeah
economically and all that I mean they've
made huge strides yeah I mean Chile
socially economically is not doing bad
at all yeah and there a couple of other
examples like that too so I'm surprised
you would say do you think it's a
regional thing or is just a country
maybe just a country maybe just a
regional thing but certainly the issue
with corruption and mismanagement and
mainly because I talked about it from
the venezuelan point of view in the fact
that it's so wealthy like a lot of
African countries but all the rich of
course but because of corruption and
mismanagement it's imploding since yeah
Marin you know what I was thinking as
you were talking I mean it makes a lot
of sense what you're saying but I all
and I couldn't blame a black person
feeling the resentment given everything
that's happened but it is tragic when
you describe it in that way because I
feel like fundamentally I don't see a
way out of that of what you're talking
about it if if essentially what you're
saying is black people get together and
they know that what you're saying in
your article is true mmm but they don't
want to admit it because they're afraid
I'm resentful mm-hmm
even though yeah I guess we would be
we'd be in agreement to society's
improving in terms of its treatment of
minorities and so on mm-hmm I don't see
a way out of that I do yeah the way out
of that is in black group success not
just individual success in group success
as I told you look at the end of the day
the key to all of this is Africa okay
because Africa is the black continent
that is the only continent where
essentially black people are the ones
running the show now the unbe you know
black thinkers going back to Marcus
Garvey Fulani Kolhapur coochy personally
a hero of mine it was a Nigeria and I'm
a musician and political activist said
this 50 years ago they said look as long
as Africa is not successful the black
person will not be respected any way in
the world okay this is the prerequisite
for blacks to be respected anywhere in
the world there must be at least a
couple of indisputably successful not
our well you know if we compare to where
it was
20 years ago and that kind of relative
kind of success we are talking about
indisputable success okay if France
success the Germany success or Japan
success or China success where nobody
can argue and say it is anything other
than a success that's what we're talking
about here now that must happen at least
a couple of countries yeah there's over
50 countries there even if it's just
four five six countries okay that people
can look at and say look these countries
good healthcare good economies strong
strong armies that success like I said
the way we understand it ma here number
one what that will do the people there
on the ground let's say in Africa
obviously will have much better lives
true there will be a much stronger sense
of pride you know if you really have an
innate sense of pride nobody and in it
sense of dignity and self-worth nobody
can take that away from you okay no
names your code can't take that away
from you it can only be taken away from
you if you don't actually really have it
if you are pretending to have it but
deep inside you don't really feel that
way then if somebody calls you a name
you know it affects you okay you might
not even see it out in public but it
affects you because you're thinking oh
maybe that person is right maybe I'm
really worthless or not worth that more
that much so one it will give people a
sense of self-worth there within Africa
okay so then Africans let's say come
into the UK or to America or to the West
discussion will discuss from a
completely different psychological
position okay
it will be from a psychological position
that look you guys white people have
your successful countries here in Europe
obviously there are some much less
successful countries here in Europe we
black people in Africa we also have our
successful countries in Africa and of
course there's some much less successful
countries there just like you guys also
have here in Europe so that'll be a
completely different psychological
approach it a much more relaxed
psychological approach you see so that's
one two if we talk about let's say black
because a lot of this is actually pushed
not even by people who were born in
Africa and then moved to the west like
me
but very often by black people who were
actually born in the West okay born in
America or born here hmm so they also I
know affected by this fact that they
know that this successful black nations
don't really exist okay
and they too if they were to see that
all welders I don't know a man in
Nigeria which is one of the lesser
becomes one of the biggest economies in
the world and world leaders go there to
pay homage to the Nigerian leader etc
this visuals appear ok when there's some
you know big global event you know
people consult or what does the Nigerian
leader think what does the South African
leader think what does the Kenyan leader
think after years of seeing these kind
of images you know in TV and all that
and seeing that look this Power Balance
which they speak of is becoming
definitely more equal okay we do see
that the black nations which are strong
and powerful the black identities in the
West here will also be sort of more
relaxed psychologically also okay
they'll be more sure of themselves and
there'll be less of this sort of
desperate need you know sort of proof by
bluster empty bluster essentially that
oh yes we are something and we're going
to show them that we're something
because you know showing that you're
something is not you know based on
bluster you the way the world is is
based on results which you have behind
you and the results of your groups
behind you yeah perhaps it shouldn't be
like that in fact I think it shouldn't
be like that I believe people should be
respected and groups should be respected
for simply being okay but that's not how
the world works you know Chinese people
thirty years ago I remember the jokes
about the Chinese people thirty years
ago you gotta share me would have
definitely read about them also thirty
years ago you know China was the butt of
you know world jokes yeah there was a
joke of the poor [ __ ] and all that
yet nobody treated them seriously they
were dismissed today nobody would dare
do that what they are knows nobody would
do that he didn't take a Chinese
identity on movement to come out and say
oh you must respect them a Chinese
people because we demand it that's not
the way it works okay the results came
the strength came people automatically
respected nobody had to be asked today
nobody has to be
to respect China do you think the West
idea of Africa as a whole doesn't help
the fact that you know you asked the
average person on the street what they
think about Africa and they would say
you know it's poverty its corruption
it's you know it's divisions of wealth
it's do you think that that's really
quite damaging when it's a country
listen sorry so
so continent you can hear is me sweating
and you know some are more successful
than others and it's quite simply a
crude two-dimensional portrait
definitely but that is still not the
core of the problem the core of the
problem is not what white people think
about Africa
the core of the problem is what are the
realities of Africa I don't care what
what people think about Africa of course
I have to care because where people are
influential and all that and all that
and of course you know what's shown on
the news on CNN etc is important but
what really matters are the realities on
the ground there if the socio-economic
realities on the ground they improve
life becomes better for people the
countries become stronger economically
etc this narrative which you're talking
about will also change because one thing
which I can't stand which black identity
Rian's do is focus on the native aspect
of things and they say oh yeah well
Africa is portrayed a mess so negatively
and you know that's why I may things are
so bad no it's portrayed negatively
because things are so bad it's not that
it's for trade negatively and that's why
things are so bad
these pictures which are shown sometimes
of children hungry etc they exist okay
they exist now the African intellectual
or the black intellectual would like to
sort of downplay that side and focus not
on the 70 80 percent who are having
terribly difficult lives but focus on
the 10 20 percent who are doing well and
so well what are you guys talking so
much about slums and all that and all
that look there's this African
businessman who built a business worth
two billion dollars fine but so what how
does that help the millions of people
who are there suffering okay I
understand why they're doing it they're
doing it from a did
the perspective from a perspective that
look if the world sees us as simply like
you're suggesting simply poor we have
nothing to offer etc no one will ever
expect us and perhaps even this economic
growth will not come because investors
won't come since they'll think oh well
you know we're so poor we have nothing
to offer anyway that's the argument
that's the perspective I get that
perspective but at the end of the day if
you're talking for instance investors
investors are not going to you know
watch CNN to decide whether to go invest
in a country or not they're going to
look at facts and figures what's the
average wage what's the average income
what kind of disposable income two
people have are they going to be able to
buy my products okay that's what they're
going to look at so that argument that
Oh sort of am talking about the
realities of Africa is gonna scare away
investors and those we won't get the
economic growth and those who are
perpetuating the poverty I don't buy
that logical sequence you know is the
other way around so it is mostly I know
on their perspective a dignity it's a
dignity it's a dignity perspectives that
dignity arguments yeah that oh we have
to sort of speak well of ourselves and
what they will say I know to people like
me is look other people speak well of
themselves they don't speak of their
disadvantages or their bad sides yeah
when Americans are talking about
themselves abroad they speak about the
good things about America when the
British are talking about themselves
abroad to speak about the good things
yeah it's not that's the thing it's not
but that's the way they will present the
something so why shouldn't we focus on
the good sides you see that's also why
should do because everybody else does it
but it's actually not like that some of
the most critical books you can find in
the world about America we're eaten by
Americans yeah and the Americans who
come out every day and sit is a rubbish
country oppressive racist etc etc just
like the way about Britain so that but I
understand you know the problem they
face is that problem of you know where's
the balance between soft criticism which
happens when we are within ourselves
okay so you go read average a manager a
newspaper today you will find article
slaying
and government policy and often even
slang Nigerian society okay but those
are articles for domestic consumption
yeah the idea is that they're not meant
to be read by white people because this
will make them even more look down on us
so as long as we know the audience is
within our circle we say the truth but
if we know white people are going to
read this we need to sort of spin it a
bit because if not we are just giving
them more opportunities to look down on
us the way you and I know is the way the
discussion will go between me and a
black person or do it like they will say
to me the way you and I know they've
always looked down on us and now you
want to give them even more I'll put you
in easy to do that another thing I want
to touch in terms of a possible solution
is one thing that's always occurred to
me is there's almost this original sin
of slavery yeah that's never been
addressed not really like you know you
talk about the fact that you know
obviously the vast vast majority of
people of all colors yeah would say that
slavery was wrong yeah specifically the
African slave trade right there's a
slaver of all kinds of happening for
millennia but people would accept that
that's wrong now but that's never been
properly addressed in the sense of yes
has been apologies but there's never
been saying economic aspect to that
right do you think that something like
targeted reparations towards people who
are the descendants of slaves may be
like educational vouchers or something
would help to kind of address that
unaddressed original sin and kind of
help us as a society to move beyond that
do you think that's possible that's an
interesting point you raise and there is
definitely an analogy that could be
drawn on to justify such a demand which
would be the analogy of the compensation
given to Holocaust survivors and their
families yeah sometimes by Swiss banks
for instance and some of the ma banks
who profited off the holocaust directly
and they've been compensation agreements
a man negotiated for the direct
descendants of those who are not for all
Jewish people exactly
so yeah I mean that's definitely an
analogy there and I definitely think
there's an argument to be made for that
there's an argument to be made for that
if you can like I said identify go to
direct descendants
there's definitely legal argument
probably could come up for that and
there's a moral argument you could come
up for that so it's definitely that's an
idea definitely because I feel like that
would be a big part of a potential
solution because otherwise the
resentments and the weariness that
you've talked about is always going to
be there you know it's like if you've
been offended by a person an individual
in your life and you're really upset
about it and you have every right to be
upset and they've never apologized or
maybe they were kind of half-heartedly
apologize they've never compensated you
they've never offered to make amends
mm-hmm then it's going to be very
difficult to have a constructive
relationship with that person and that's
why whenever these issues are put up I
always feel like I mean the descendants
of slaves have not been given the
rightful compensation what's happened
and if that could be taken care of I
feel like we could move on as a society
in a way that we haven't been able to
this like I said again that's it that's
definitely a hugely interesting idea and
there is definitely a movement in the US
and trying to demand that of course we
would go into Holocaust survivors I
guess it's easier to identify because it
wasn't that long ago so there's still
some people even still alive and their
children definitely or grandchildren
definitely still alive a bit more
difficult than with slavery you'd have
to go back you know trace records etc so
who would actually get the composition
would it be the African Americans or
would it also extend to some of their
African descendants in Africa okay so
practically obviously it would be much
more difficult and it will be much more
difficult to do but I definitely agree
with you that from a symbolic point of
view of sort of an olive branch let's
say in this case cash towards addressing
some of this emotion and most
importantly would remove some of the
emotional impact or some of the
psychological advantages we
the identitarian have who are trying to
drive that permanent wedge they'd have
one less argument okay
they'd have one less argument so people
will be able to say okay fine boy you
say this why people are so bad okay we
know what they've did and they've done
in the past and all that but at least
you know they've now trying to address
this by ABC yeah
so you know that's so you know some
people listening would be like oh yeah
maybe this you know identity guys not
taking it too far
because I've told these people have
given some compensation now what else
you want them to do you know so yeah so
from that point of view as in one
addressing some of the issues and
weakening the position of those who want
to simply whose careers are built
essentially on driving that wedge and
saying look we black people are victims
is why people are bad etc etc even
though funny enough all these identities
I've never seen any of them who's who go
to a black publisher to publish their
books they always go to white publishers
why because the white publishers are
white publishing companies are the
biggest ones who can make you famous and
make you sell loads of books but if
you're talking about strengthening and
you have talking about black power and
strengthening you know black economics
something why not go to a black
publishing company such exists it's not
like they're no black owned publishing
companies that you know that is the
Assam which function on the market they
are definitely in Africa and I would
almost 100 percent sure that they are
some black own publishing companies in
America so why don't these black
identity runs go to black publishing
companies to publish their books of
course not because those ones one can't
pay them as much for their books and so
can't make them as famous as they you
know let me know mention names company
can so you see yes some of the you know
irony and some of the hypocrisy of the
whole thing yeah you know I'm here
complaining about how terrible you know
white people are but at the end of the
day you know I'm going to avoid a
publishing complain because I know
they're the ones who gonna make me
famous and eventually you know rich or
semi rich beside the NASA scientist
maybe
[Music]
if I ever want to start an argument on
the internet or if anybody starts an
argument on the Internet all they need
to do is put two words together white
and privileged and all of a sudden it
explodes and you know you've got people
from different sides end of the argument
and it normally gets incredibly heated I
mean what is your opinion of this do you
think a is exists is it a thing and how
big a problem is it in our society so
Britain you're talking about
yes Britain or the u.s. is well I'll
definitely say that white skin color is
a strong negotiating currency in global
interactions okay
for instance if a white man goes into
walks into a Nigerian police station and
complains about a crime being committed
against them that crime will be taken
much more seriously that reports will be
taking much more seriously than if in
Nigerian was to go into that police
station and complain about the same
crime okay so why is that it's because
the definitely is and now I'm starting
with an example
like I said in Nigeria it's because the
Nigerian policeman definitely
instinctively believes that you know my
people are important in Russia where I'm
from if a Nigerian or a British man
walked into a police station to report
crime yeah a foreigner yeah that would
also be taken more seriously wouldn't
you what type of foreigner is it not
that the Westerner would take yes
Western the Western but that Western it
could be black that Western or latina I
know Western I'll get I'll get I'll
guess what I said yeah it's a good point
I'm I know we are going to so
essentially the nigel put the weapon I
put now why is it just because of the
skin colour just because this wrinkle
looks like that sir no it's because of
the perception that white people are
generally rich
and generally powerful okay that's why
they are important not because they are
white but because of the resources that
I imagined to be behind them okay so the
Nigerian policeman there would assume
that well first of all we should take
this guy's case seriously because you
know he might know some important people
here for instance there might be some
consequences if we don't take the case
seriously etc it's not because of the
white skin color it's because of the
resources they imagine behind that white
person who walked into the police
station whereas if it was the Nigerian
person who if they don't identify that
oh this is a rich guy here they'll just
you know dismiss that you know well we
don't have to take this serious and
there'll be no consequences and this
leads to what you are talking about as
in why for instance in Russia if a
Western person a Western citizen walks
in they will be taking more seriously
for instance a black American they will
be taking a hundred times I'm sure more
seriously than if a Nigerian walks into
a Russian police station
because the black Americans an American
citizen okay so because there's that
perception that you know behind this guy
there are resources there's political
power there's economic power so we have
to take this person seriously it's the
same thing exactly for instance in
Poland you know Western people you know
walk somewhere etcetera it's taken very
seriously because this is a British
person oh my god Polish police would
also take probably more seriously the
case of your British person than the
case even of a Polish person you know so
so these are these are dynamics which
come into play like I said based on
resources etc and it so happens that
it's white people who control a lot of
the resources etc that's why this
preferential treatment comes in because
our preferential treatment definitely
exists okay so that's in the in let's
say Nigerian setting so if we come let's
say to the setting here in the UK
clearly a group which constitutes 87% of
like
UK's population will have advantages
okay we'll find it easier to you know
get jobs etc and why might that be let's
say for instance you go apply for a job
recently I was on scan is a couple of
weeks ago talking about there was a
shortage of oh there is a shortage sorry
of senior man
senior minority managers in the NHS so I
spoke to a couple of people I know in
the NHS swap in high executive positions
both black and white on why they think
this is the case and what was
interesting what some of the black
people and they told me they said look
you know you come obviously to be even
called for an interview on such a level
you know senior management position the
NHS this means there's already an
assumption that you are qualified to do
the job because if not you won't even be
called in for the interview anyway okay
so based on your CV they've seen these
guys qualified to do the job then you
comment and they make a short list etc
now the whole crux of the matter comes
in who in that short list is going to be
chosen so let's say you have four or
five people
let's see one is black one is Asian
three are white what are the thoughts
that are going to be going through the
head of the mostly white panelists or
all white panelists in making that final
decision we know all these five guys can
do the job they are all qualified now
thoughts will start to enter okay who do
we think will have the smoothest working
relationship with okay in answering that
question will start to come now
imaginations of cultural affinity okay
am I going to be able to get along with
this guy you know almost without words
because that's the kind of person I want
to work with yeah I don't want to work
with somebody who you know I'll be
worried whether I can say this or I
can't say that or should I say this word
shouldn't I say that way every culture
has its code like you know for instance
in Russia that the way Russians can
communicate with each other without
words that a foreigner will never
understand if just reading the words who
black what was communicated here yeah
but the Russian knows exactly what was
communicated and here now come in
questions of are okay so you know most
probably will get along better with the
white guy cause I mean he's white like
us he probably you know grew up in him
not probably grew up in a similar
culture probably has similar world used
to us similar attitudes towards you know
I don't know work different kind of
things and it you simply probably be
easier for us to get along with our
person and on that is on that basis a
decision can be made to employ a white
guy instead of let's say for instance
someone who came to Britain from Nigeria
20 years ago and has exactly the same
qualifications yeah now that decision is
not I'm not saying sometimes it's not
based on racism probably it is but
sometimes it's not based on the fact
that oh I think this black guy is a
worse person or will not be able to do
the job but it's based on the fact that
I simply think I'll get along better
with the white guy yeah
and now these are not thoughts that only
go through the heads of white people in
Nigeria for instance you know where
there's ethnic divisions and regions of
the country have vastly different
cultures in Nigeria for instance it's a
huge country four times the size of the
UK four times the size of the UK not of
England of the entire UK almost 200
million people so in the northern region
there's a different culture for instance
than in the southern region okay and
very often also when decisions are made
for instance in Nigeria based on who to
employ etc these kinds of considerations
are taken into account
my father was an architect here on his
own architectural firm in Nigeria he
only employed people from within his own
ethnic group not because he hated the
people from other ethnic groups but he
simply made an automatic assumption that
you know he'd have a smoother working
relationship with him from zone ethnic
same culture we understand each other I
don't need to say much okay I say one
towards you know what I mean
that's why that's why it is I can't
remember anybody I'm talking about a few
dozen people mad but who are not from
his ethnic group and it's not because
others from other ethnic groups did not
apply or because my dad hated those
people from those ethnic groups you know
so these are the kinds of mechanisms
that could happen like in a setting here
that the word but they'll go for there
you know and then it would be identified
as oh it's racism it's because they
think the black person is worse or they
don't want to work at Lover's no it's a
preferential choice now of course these
disadvantages people like me
or could disadvantaged people like me or
other black people so I'm not surprised
that you know nobody's going to just say
ah well okay fine since it's just about
cultural affinity then we understand
then it's okay obviously that expects
minorities to adopt that position
because this disadvantages them yeah
but I'm just trying to show how some of
the mechanisms behind such decisions are
not based on oh I think black people are
war so I don't want to work with black
people yeah or other minorities but on
these you know and cultural preferential
treatments I'm talking about of course
the question would be you know what's
the solution because it's unfair
obviously if qualified black people or
Asian people are disadvantaged because
the white person making the decision you
know
assumes they will work better with a
friend a white person yeah
well the thing is what that is is what
you're talking about I mean it doesn't
sound to me like this actually got
anything to do with race whatsoever
that same thing it might but what I'm
saying is that same thing would apply to
class yeah so a group of middle class
people seeing a working-class person or
the BBC yeah they would then go this
person we can't get on with him he's
working class of course he know about me
in the same position because they'd be
like well Keith didn't grow up here of
course of course and I mean they're
pause look if they see these things okay
white haha another point if they say
okay this thing is older white privilege
cetera I know Polish people here who
came to this country with master's
degrees in economics and we're washing
plates for five years okay why because
one the English wasn't that good and
during job interviews for the you know
specialization economics etc they
weren't able to convince the usually
British employer that you know I can do
this job and I'll understand
instructions immediately you know you
know nobody has time to start explaining
things to you all because you're an
immigrant so taken are to explain things
to you unfortunately it's the Brutes our
world capitalism nobody has time for
that people want I want somebody who I
see a and they understand the rest of
the sentence so I know Polish people
like that so how has their white skin
help them here
Britain in always has it helped them
okay
the British apply is not interested that
all polish guy you're white are so I'll
employ you of course not you know if you
don't speak the language
a black Britain who's finished a good
University here in Britain is advantaged
over the white pole if they both have
economics degrees yeah the black britain
who you know grew up here knows the
cultural codes went to a good university
will be hugely advantage over a white
poll who came here has the same
economics degree but you know doesn't
maybe speak English that well and Kant
doesn't know you know those British
cultural codes and all that that well
yeah so you know what would we call that
then yeah no I totally agree do you
think do you think we've gone too far in
entertaining the black identity runs
that you talk about and identity
politics in general and what do you mean
by that too far I mean I mean that we're
starting to see like I saw on my
Facebook feed someone sent me this
morning that the government has an
initiative to change the ethnic makeup
of the firefighting service okay
cuz it doesn't reflect whatever it is
diversity quarters that they have and in
that kind of situation you know most
people I suspect would think well hey I
don't care what color my fireman is I
just want him to drag me out so many fun
sure sure sure
look these are tricky issues up I've had
such an experience and my wife recently
had surgical procedure and I remember
when we were in the hospital in
Sheffield there you know the last thing
on my mind was was the skin color of the
people running this hospital or the
doctors or the people who are turning to
it I was the last thing on my mind all I
cared about was that you know M these
are people who are committed a good at
their job okay so that's one side of it
the other side of it and I definitely
think is a legitimate argument is if
there are let's see specific
organizations or institutions okay where
after really going in and doing research
not just something within the
instruments but after going in and doing
research and studying you know
recruitment processes and all that how
people are employed what kind of people
applied how many ways something
there seems to be a clear tendency to
sort of dismiss minority applicants then
of course I believe that should be
looked into you know how do we look why
is this happening how do we address this
etc of course so I can't say much
regarding the fire and Fire Brigade
Americal I don't know you know what made
the government come up with that kind of
comfort that kind of something you know
I would assume that the you know did
some kind of studies and did some kind
of research before they came up with
that you know proposal yeah it was going
to lead on to the question because this
is something that I've tossed and turned
over in my head many many times do you
believe in quotas do you think we should
impose on employers you shouldn't you
should employ this percentage of women
you should employ this percentage of
ethnic minorities or do you think that
the market should be allowed to sort
itself out to be honest with you I don't
have a clear I'm an agnostic on that
position on that issue I don't really
have a Claire I don't really have a
clear opinion on that issue in the sense
that my opinion has shifted over the
years so there have been moments I might
wake up on a Monday and think quotas are
terrible ideas ridiculous come on why
should the company be forced to etc etc
but then I read an article on a
Wednesday which makes a persuasive
argument for why let's say in
institution a there were no
possibilities for let's say women to get
jobs but after an in putting the
imposition of quarters those women have
you know there's been a greater and a
position of women and the results of the
institution have improved you know and
then I read that and I'm like simply
scolding in such a bad idea after all so
yeah so honestly speaking I don't have a
clear-cut idea that I would say probably
it should go on a case-by-case basis on
a case by case case basis
I definitely probably wouldn't support a
you know blanket quota you know
everywhere you know fifty percent of the
men
must be a woman 50% of the people in
Parliament or the MPs must be women or
21.2% should be black etc I definitely
wouldn't support something like that but
on a case by case basis looking at
specific institutions organizations
looking at the history how things have
worked there then I think definitely I
mean it's not something I would dismiss
on cos rubbish idea so moving on you
obviously political journalists and you
have be based in Poland and Eastern
Europe and we've seen the rise of
populism happen more more in those
countries yeah it's hungry as Poland and
all the rest of it why do you think this
is happening is it to do with the EU is
it to do with you know the you know the
situation in the mid in the Middle East
or Syria why do you think it's happening
in its is it something we should be
worried about definitely yes in Portland
currently there's a hardcore right-wing
right-wing a xenophobic had called them
I try to use that word sparingly but
definitely it applies in this case and
my government so okay I'll just tell you
briefly how they came into power so they
won elections they've been in power
since 2015 and that will of course the
year of the migrant crisis okay now this
party before for reasons completely
unconnected with migrants or immigration
etc we're already in a good position to
win the elections okay because Poland
had had a ruling party liberal ruling
party for eight years people were tired
of it there been some corruption
scandals etc so there was already fat
around for this opposition party to win
those elections okay
so during the summer of 2015 the
elections were in October if I recall
correctly of 2015 during the summer they
were a head of the Liberal Party but by
a few points then the migrant crisis ma
erupted and they you know went into that
hardcore as in the leader of the party
came out and said we should
accepting any refugees or migrants into
Poland they could be Carney I mean
terrible things saying like oh they
could even be carrying diseases and all
that you know which are terrible
delusions so you know what is absurd
about the Jews in Nazi Germany etc you
know basically that's playing on the
most fundamental fear of people you know
that these guys could come and give you
a disease which could make you die you
know what's more scary than that so they
you know played into this and troops
very strongly immediately they do that I
knew that one day actions and you didn't
want the elections unfortunately and as
it happened in October it came that they
did win the elections so I'd say that
definitely added a few points to them
even though most probably they might
have even won the elections even without
that so what happened is when they saw
that wow people are really responding to
this stuff yeah that it might be in cuz
you know we're talking they were talking
then the previous government and the
Liberal government who they ran against
had agreed to accept 7,000 refugees just
a thousand no no no just 7,000 and and
this government said all and these guys
who are ruling now during the cappuccino
yeah but that's how they start they say
7,000 and then you know people come in
and they bring in their brothers and
sisters and cousins and before you know
it is a hundred thousand yeah and then
before you know it is a million so
that's how they played on that and he
said so we are accepting zero that's our
policy
so they want elections and then when
they say wow it's in people really like
this stuff they're only responding to it
then they even started going further and
then the way you know when there were
attacks you remember 2016 there was you
know the attacks in France and all that
you know and then you know their
ministers of commerce and say well you
know we've said all along this
multiculturalism is a ridiculous idea
you know you guys see now how right we
we're not to allow these Muslim folks to
come you know into Poland and all that
because probably you know Poland now
would be like France now you know we're
you know this people running around with
ak-47 shooting people in cafes and you
know obviously you know that fear etc
and those attacks sort of reinforced
their message people were like they
probably had a point
you know and they've been riding on that
since then I'm definitely they've sort
of unleashed not at the end of the day
Bertrand Russell I think it was who who
wrote in history of Western philosophy
that the history of humanity has been
one of the battle between reason and
passion within the individual human yeah
and that for some people the victory of
reason of a passion comes without much
pain for some people it comes with a lot
of pain and restraining those passions
defined inhibitive and even
psychologically difficult to accept they
want to be able to release themselves on
vents in public and not have to pretend
and act all polite uncivilized and all
that and I do believe very strongly you
know he got em there's a lot there's a
lot to that and so I think when this
rhetoric started in Poland it simply
allowed a lot of people who had been
dissatisfied with various aspects of
liberalism from its attitudes
immigration to its attitudes to gay
rights and things like that cause
Poland's a very conservative society
compared to a country like Britain
incomparably so I'll give you an example
I hope I'm not varying off too much I
tend to do this in Poland no leftist
party has dared to postulate for gay
marriage here in the UK the conservative
supported it so you see you see that the
difference so this when they started
electric it allowed a lot of people
who'd been hiding feelings which they
had on various topics regarded to
liberalism and you know freedom and all
that to be able to come out and say oh
yes finally now I can say this you know
I've never really liked this Muslims
can't stand gays and think you know the
West has basically gone crazy you know
and these are really motions which
people feel they're not manufactured
because very often people try to sort of
act as if always this elites who
manufacture did you know they tell
people things and then people like
robots say ah ok immigrants
haha immigrants but you know gays but I
guess bad no it's doesn't work that way
there has to be a feeling inside you
yeah that is already leaning towards
that direction and then when the
politician comes out and says you know
constantan it's okay to think immigrants
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't be afraid of saying that come on
yourself be free you know that's what
they played on you know and it's working
so in - so your question was is it a
problem I think definitely is a problem
because there's a lot of nastiness there
I mean there are of course those who are
opposed to it to this yeah but you know
it gives a lot of people sort of
satisfaction you know there's a human
satisfaction in feeling that I am better
than somebody else okay so if you are a
broke guy who hasn't and I'm not saying
this disparagingly I'm just as a fact if
you're somebody who lets is let's call
it economically frustrated things
haven't gone well for you in life you
don't have such a high level of
self-esteem and all that and then a
politician comes to you and says look
forget about your individual status you
I superior being simply for the fact
that you were born a poll that alone
makes you better than all those Muslims
and all those brown people and all those
Africans and all those people that alone
should give you pride you know and
you're like yeah you know I am something
at the end of the day yeah and you know
it works very strongly especially on
people like that who have that low sense
of of self-esteem and then you tell him
that Oh actually you don't have to have
any achievements in life individually
all you have to do is have been born
polish that alone makes you somebody you
know it's automatic and effort on your
part and introspect as I presume
you were studying which is group
identity which is yeah yeah definitely
yeah and it gives him an identity and
therefore a sense of self-worth no of
course not there's various social
identity theories and which persuasively
I would say may argue that you know a
lot of our individual self-esteem often
in many people if not most is derived
from the group they belong to under
group esteem you know there are some
people who are able to sort of derive
that sense of self-esteem and in it
depends on also the dynamics political
dynamics from their individual
achievements yeah I did this I did that
I did this ok but a lot of people really
it actually especially if you don't have
those individual achievements if you
can't say oh I have this or I've done
that or I've done this I've done that
then you are looking for something to
give you that esteem and then somebody
gives it to you on a platter of gold
dude you don't have to have done
anything in your life the fact that you
were born British or polish makes you a
superior person already that's all you
need come on who wouldn't want that it's
easy man this is what I think the
traditional kind of classical liberalism
yes such an powerful antidote to
identity politics because if you teach
people that your value and your status
and everything about your life depends
on your individual your behavior on how
you conduct yourself on what you
yourself achieved then people who are in
that position who understand the world
through that lens and then we're going
to be drawn to the racism of the
far-right yeah what to this identitarian
as Muslims are left because they
understand that fundamentally it's your
job as a human being to take the
circumstances and which you're born and
to do the best possible that you can in
those circumstances and I think that's
why we talk about these issues with a
lot of people because I think that
message of individual responsibility has
to be spread as far as and while it's
possible in my opinion because the we
there's the identity politics on the
right hand left I think is very
dangerous the problem with that and with
that
with what you propose is that it's
difficult oh yeah
it's difficult it's what is easier for
me to say okay my life depends on my
individual effort and what I have done
okay
and if let's say I haven't reached the
stage in life or I don't have the kind
of esteem within society that I thought
I would have then probably this is my
fault
is that easier to do or is it easier for
me to believe that if there is something
going on in my life which if I am NOT
where I wanted to be then it's because
of somebody else of course the second
option is much easier it's much more
attractive it's much more seductive okay
telling people look it depends on you
that's putting your pushing the
responsibility on people that's
difficult okay because then there's no
excuses there's no one to blame you know
people don't want that very often people
don't want that they want to be able to
say Lou it's not my fault come on
something somebody must have caused
these problems you know and that's why
you're acting populism and stuff you
know it's so seductive because you're
you take you sort of lift the burden of
responsibility from the individual you
know and say oh it's not your fault it's
because of these people right you know
unemployed because you haven't studied
well oh wow so I'm not that crap after
all yes yeah well listen it's been an
absolutely I open aim to be fantastic to
have you on you're probably one of the
more the most intelligent and kind of
new words guess we were trying to take
you gay to take some extreme position
but it's been fantastic the question we
always like to end on is is the one
thing that you think where the society
aren't talking about that we ought to be
talking about not really honestly
speaking I mean the big issue which I
think up I think there's two issues
which are going to sort of shape
political discussion in the next 5-10
years and that's identity and inequality
okay and we talked about the identity
issue today and
talk about identity politics the second
issue is inequality and I can't say I
mean whatever I'm you you you you may
think of him right now etcetera but you
know carbon and Libra et cetera they've
been attacking that issue very strongly
and they've been talking about it very
strongly which i think is one issue
which labor is winning on right now the
inequality issue the Conservatives are
winning on the identity issue labour is
winning on the inequality which hold on
certain how are the Conservatives
winning on that identity the identity
issue because the Conservatives you know
one half sort of at least you know in
official rhetoric and said look we
respect the brexit decision of the
British people to leave the European
Union so basically we accept that bridge
provider and I want to stay British or a
more persistent European however you may
choose to portray that so we accept that
definitely okay so clearly I would argue
and the Conservative Party have always
placed more emphasis on things like
patriotism you know love in Britain etc
yeah Dan for instance and the left which
is really very critical yeah so on these
issues I would say I'm probably at I
don't know if there's been such a survey
but I would assume that if Brits were
asked for instance which is the more
patriotic party I'm pretty much sure
they would say the Conservatives are the
more patriotic pass the Tories are the
more patriotic party whereas if they
were asked which is the party which is
addressing inequalities more talking
about inequalities more they would
probably say it's labour talking about
inequalities motion you know so the
party and the political movement which
is able to provide an adequate response
to these two issues owns the political
future in Britain and in Europe and in
the West fascinating thank you so much
for coming on before we let you go your
Twitter handle is actually I do Cory are
one perfect so we'll send everybody your
way and thank you very much for tuning
in this week we've got more fantastic
interviews coming up we hope you
got it and we'll see you soon yeah ups
and they'll probably be a new presenter
cuz I'll be fine I'll fire you right no
and as always remember to subscribe to
our channel if you enjoy and if you
already subscribed remember to click
that Bell button next to subscribe
button so that you get notified whenever
we release a fantastic interview like
this we're on Twitter and other social
media at trigger pod follow us comment
suggesting you guess for us to talk to
and have a good week
[Music]